[Musique]
à
le plus grand parc animalier public de
france cévennes propriété du muséum
d'histoire naturelle là où tu en chutant
sur 436 hectares dont 150 dans clôt
chaque jour les équipes de soigneurs et
tout le personnel consacre une grande
partie de leur journée à nourrir et
améliorer le quotidien des animaux c'est
pas bien ben si tu peux regarder au
système de des sangliers
si ça fonctionne la trappe 8h30 les
équipes du jour reçoivent brièvement les
derniers recommandations avant de
charger leurs véhicules
trois tournées permettent de nourrir 14
cents animaux répartis en 120 espèces la
cuisine le poumon du parc
ici on prépare les repas et ce n'est pas
une mince affaire
elise y travaille depuis deux ans une on
savait ce que tous les jours deux et
donc il y en a un qui fera la partie
granulés et là ça va lui prendre à peu
près une heure ou deux heures par jour à
préparer les rations granulés et tout ce
qui est partie fruits et légumes
c'est une autre personne et là on va
dire un peu plus d'une demi journée pour
pas vrai toutes les races pommes
carottes courgettes fenouil sellerie
salade sans oublier viandes et poissons
elise sans mémoriser parfaitement ses
menus qui en plus varie selon les
saisons
[Musique]
pour donner une idée de la complexité de
cette préparation
il n'existe pas moins de dix sept sortes
de granit et spécifiques en plus du
granulé vrac élise adjoint une étiquette
sur chaque conteneur chaque chariot
correspond à une tournée
les quantités consommées sont
impressionnantes 17 tonnes de céréales
autant de granulés 11 de fruits et
légumes 30 de viande et le poisson
surgelé
sans oublier 116 tonnes de fourrage mais
la nourriture sert aussi de vecteurs de
communication auprès du public
donc là vous avez vous avez un lémurien
qui a une entière confiance
c'est notre se mêlent adultes qui est là
parce qu'elle est assise dans le plateau
avec moi et puis sapphire qui est un
petit peu moins confiance qui a toujours
le contact avec une de ses pattes avec
le grillage ou une branche
parce que s'il arrive un truc on sait
jamais elle peut sauver patrick roux est
un scientifique éthologue c'est-à-dire
spécialiste du comportement animal
directeur des collections du parc il est
spécialiste des lemuria il anime
aujourd'hui il ateliers programmés pour
le public
toujours remettre en perspective ce qui
fait la spécificité du parc de la hotoie
il ya quatre animations par jour avec
certes un soigneur ou un animateur ou
moi même
et oui c'est super important cet aspect
d'explication auprès du public de
sensibilisation du public parce que
c'est le rôle de tous les parcs déjà de
le faire est d'autant plus un parc du
muséum qui nous avons vraiment un rôle
d'éducation du public
on présente des aspects sont super
intéressante visuellement très mignonne
mais il faut aussi savoir que si on est
pris ici on est présente et qui est
derrière est un travail d'étude de
l'animal de reproduction de conservation
peut être un jour de réintroduction dans
leur milieu d'origine
la grande majorité des gens qui viennent
à l'eau tous sont sensibles au thème de
la conservation et la protection
environnementale animan que l'animal
comme comme flore maintenant il faut que
quand ils partent d'ici qu'ils arrivent
chez eux et bien que ce qu'ils ont
appris ici avec nous et puisque le faire
aussi à la maison par des petits gestes
ce qu'on parle bien sûr des animaux
exotiques mais on parle aussi de la
faune locale et de la protection de la
biodiversité locale
cinquante mille visiteurs par an en
voiture
la pied en vélo en calèche ou en golf
est parti pour les circuits du parc près
de 9 kilomètres en tout à la découverte
des animaux mais aussi de la flore
elise a délaissé la cuisine pour sa
tournée quotidienne et parmi ses
pensionnaires justement la nurserie de
cistude cette tortue qu'on trouve en
brenne fait l'objet depuis 2007 d'un
programme de sauvegarde de l'espèce
grâce aux canidés réintroduction en
milieu naturel au lac du bourget en
savoie ont pu commencer
apparemment couronnée de succès
non loin de là l'équipe de soins est
aussi à pied d'oeuvre sandra l'avait
d'ordinaire accompagné de benjamin
étudiant stagiaire et de deux soigneurs
dont emmanuel le chef mission du moment
capturer une grue sauvage électrocuté
soigner au parc on a tous des rôles qui
se complète en fait les soigneurs sont
là au quotidien vont voir les animaux
tous les jours ceux qui vont déceler les
petits changements de comportement les
premiers signes de maladie ou de
blessures si on a et donc du coup on se
fie à leur avis et on se déplace souvent
sur sur leurs appels et ensuite c'est
aussi une aide pour nous aider à
capturer les animaux et à faire les
interventions dont les meilleures
conditions possibles après avoir
immobilisé l'oiseau sandra photographes
ils appelèrent les indications
précieuses pour une utilisation
ultérieure et pour sa collègue appelé à
soigner elle aussi l'oiseau les deux
vétérinaires du parc ont des missions
multiples il ya pas mal de boulot et du
coup ben il ya des choses qu'on peut pas
prévoir des urgences contre est au jour
le jour en fonction de ce qui est le
plus urgent et après il ya certaines
enfin certaines choses qu'on peut
prévoir donc tout ce qui est la
prévention des maladies
à tout travail en amont que ça on peut
un peu plus planifiés et du coup les
urgences se greffent au milieu de ces
interventions la toux ceux qui sont
prévus
réputés pour leur capacité à imiter les
sons les gris du gabon sont en colères
leurs soigneurs ont pour mission de les
attraper
on évite les captures amant que ce soit
nécessaire là c'est juste qu'on a des
individus qui a une lésion à l'arrière
de la tête et
c'est ça qui nous fait penser qu'ils ont
peut-être des poux et du coup ses
membres à ce moment là on ne traite pas
par dessus les oiseaux en seront quittes
pour une belle frayeur et quelques
minutes de repos forcé dans un panier
achats avant de retrouver leur liberté
soigner un animal n'est pas toujours
facile il faut parfois isolés la bête
comme cette femelle qui se retrouve loin
de sa marque préférée et de ses
congénères mais heureusement avec ses
deux petits c'est une des spécificités
de la auto show c'est qu'on a des goûts
des très grands enclos
donc c'est vrai que d'un point de vue
vétérinaire sa demande d'une
organisation un petit peu différente
mais bon avec du temps un petit peu de
ruse on parvient toujours à capturer les
animaux qui ont eu besoin et à faire les
soins qui s'imposent si chaque équipe le
semble bien isolé au regard de
l'immensité des lieux le cordon
ombilical est bien là tous ceux qui
partent n'oublie jamais leur talkie
walkie qui les relie entre tout le temps
qu'on communique par tokyo mais on a
tout un processus
en cas d' alerte pour évacuer les gens
si ça devait arriver
et puis c'est de trouver la halle si un
animal devait s'échapper l'endormir
votre stock il a la particularité de
s'ils devaient se retrouver en position
horizontale pendant un certain temps de
déclencher une alarme et le chef
soigneur doit voir qui est en alarme et
va s'en inquiéter appelé la personne et
ça personne ne répond pas on va voir
c'est pour prévenir en cas de malaise
par exemple ou autre
[Musique]
aaron est le dernier soigneur embauché à
la haute-touche a tourné la tournée une
l'emmène à la rencontre d'une centaine
d'animaux très variés aujourd'hui il a
du mal à faire bouger certains de ses
pensionnaires
on les attrape la semaine dernière pour
faire des soins et du coup elle est donc
maintenant ils ont peur qu on les
attrape à chaque fois ça va leur prendre
voilà une semaine voire deux semaines
pour avoir confiance et j'ai oublié ce
qui s'est passé heureusement les porcs
épics semblent eux de belle humeur est
prêt à apprécier leur nourriture
l'heure du repas est l'occasion de voir
de près des animaux les temps africain
attire les visiteurs pour ce rendez vous
gourmand orchestré de main de maître par
juliette difficile de rester insensible
au spectacle
[Musique]
e
pour l'an prochain j'espère que les
petits pandas à voir arriver j'espère
que les taquins vont arriver on a
d'autres projets plus en terme d'accueil
du public et de faire une une belle zone
aussi de deux espaces de jeux pour les
enfants parce que voilà on gère aussi
pour s'amuser on pathologique et
j'espère effectivement dit dans l'est
dans les années à venir pouvoir
développer cette orientation
présentation par thématique
biogéographique c'est à dire développer
quelque chose depuis lisible sur l'asie
développer quelque chose depuis 18 sur
madagascar sur l'amérique du sud et
cetera et ça c'est un train des volées
par rapport aux visiteurs et l'autre
volet c'est la continuité de la
diversité de nos activités de recherche
roland simo le directeur du parc
orchestre toutes les missions au
quotidien
aujourd'hui deux chercheurs spécialistes
des primates sont en visite dans les
lieux pour voir les possibilités
offertes par le pas un des objectifs
aussi du muséum national d'histoire
naturelle et de pouvoir consignés par
zoologique et diffusion auprès du grand
public avec la recherche et donc d'avoir
des lieux d'expérimentation au sein même
des espaces qui sont dédiées au grand
public et le cas de la haute touche est
unique en france
ce qu'on aimerait pouvoir faire c'est
avoir des installations similaires pour
pouvoir faire des observations sur les
primates haussier en sortant du safari
voiture qui commence la visite avant
d'arriver au parking le visiteur
attentif aura peut-être remarqué ce
modeste bâtiment
le laboratoire de la aux puces est un
lieu unique en france
l'équipe de recherche de là où touch est
une très petite équipe mais nous sommes
reconnus au niveau international pour
notre expertise dans différents domaines
la procréation assistée chez les espèces
sauvages
l'étude des comportements la médecine
vétérinaire également nous cherchons à
diversifier encore notre expertise
financé depuis une quinzaine d'années le
laboratoire a mis au point des
techniques de reproduction très
sophistiqué
c'est une clio tech assez originale
puisqu'elle est constitué de
d'échantillons cryoconservés de semences
ont donc de sperme mais également dans
moyon donc sont des échantillons qui ont
conservée dans l'azoté liquide à -120 16
degrés est qui nous permettent de
stocker le patrimoine génétique précieux
des espèces les plus rares du parc
donc là dans les différents petits
containers on a quasiment 400 individus
issus de 35 espèces différentes
collectées sur le parc
donc c'est un petit trésor pour la
retouche
[Musique]
actuellement l'équipe travaille sur la
préservation des marques or un animal
dont les trois sous-espèces représente à
peine 2500 individus en liberté dans le
monde
dans leur nouvel enclos ils offrent aux
spectateurs un spectacle apaisé bien
loin des menaces qui dessinent leurs
populations
[Musique]
sur les chemins du parc les visiteurs se
font plus rares la journée s'achève
l'heure de rentrer les animaux qu'ils le
doivent
l'occasion d'assister au repas des
guépards la dernière tournée ville de
sécurité s'achève les animaux retrouvent
leurs habitudes nocturnes et la nature
reprend ses droits